we've just lowered now this is the
modern way of death in Ojai neshama sana
Tata bar Tabora he nearly fifty people
attending this zum funeral online with
only a handful by the graveside if you
know what to put some soil in families
robbed of the normal ways to grieve for
rabbi miriam berger it meant using zoom
to conduct her own grandfather's funeral
after he died of coronavirus having all
of those faces on the screen by knowing
that we could see into each other's eye
is via those camera screens actually
created an intimacy that you don't think
of within a virtual world but while
providing some solace for now she
acknowledges there will be long-term
repercussions so much of this feels
different and surreal and unreal i think
that we will not totally understand what
trauma society has been through perhaps
for many years the crisis is changing
the way we deal with all matters
relating to death death cafes niche
gatherings of strangers who talk about
all aspects of dying have been inundated
they've moved online and a turning
people away any topic you want to talk
about relating to death dying life Cove
it'd knock Ovid Caroline runs a death
cafe in London we're already seeing our
death cafes filling up within 24 hours
obviously covet has become such it's
become sort of like the the bogeyman
hasn't it at the moment so you know a
lot of people are carrying a lot of
anxiety around we're very much here not
to direct any discussion and but to just
select a conversation faux Marais is an
end of life doula who supports the dying
and their families she also runs a death
cafe and has seen more people than ever
wanting to talk and plan their own death
people are aware of their finite life
certainly and we've always had finite
lives but we've always avoided that
thought and the fact that now it's very
much in the forefront of our minds with
a lot of people also thinking you know
what's important to me and what do I
need to put in place to protect my
family should something happen to me and
as long as lockdown goes on the business
of death and grieving will continue to
evolve and adapt lucy casa sky news